all right tonight while the crisis at
the southern border has no end in sight
we do have good news to report on the
ongoing pandemic
according to the centers for disease
control vaccinated people can travel
safely within the united states and
remember there
are now three approved vaccines which
will soon be available
for everyone across the country
regardless of age or pre-existing
conditions
well except in vermont if you're under
50 you can only get the vaccine in
vermont if you
quote identify as a person of color
meanwhile a few weeks ago on cnn the
former president of planned parenthood
turned cnn medical analyst bashed
states for relaxing their lockdown
measures
see according to this medical analyst
if people get their freedoms back how
would the biden administration
force them to get a vaccine watch this
we need to make it clear to them that
the vaccine is the ticket back to
pre-pandemic life
and the window to do that is really
narrowing i mean you were mentioning
chris about how
all these states are reopening they're
reopening at a hundred percent
and we have a very narrow window to tie
reopening policy
to vaccination status because otherwise
if everything is reopened
then what's the carrot going to be how
are we going to incentivize people to
actually get the vaccine
so that's why i think the cdc and the
obama administration needs to come out a
lot
bolder and say if you're vaccinated you
can do
all these things here all these freedoms
that you have
because otherwise people are going to go
out and enjoy these freedoms anyway
yeah get the vaccine or else now i got
the vaccine my wife got the vaccine
but you know what someone might want to
remind cnn that in the united states of
america freedom is bequeathed from
god it's not from mother government and
the americans have the right to choose
whether or not they get vaccinated
we chose to do it but if my neighbor
decides not to do that
that's their business not cnn's business
not joe biden's business
not kamala hairs but kamala harris's
business
well joining us now with the reaction is
former hud secretary and one of our
favorites dr ben carson
i'm going to call you a doctor if that's
okay with you i think that's a higher
calling than being secretary but thanks
so much for joining us
what do you when you see me this medical
analyst to react and say that hey we
better coerce these people into taking
this vaccine or we're just not going to
give them their their freedoms back
how do you react to that
well it's distressing because america
is a place that people came to from all
over the world because they wanted to be
free and what we should be doing
as far as vaccinations are concerned is
convincing people
not coercing people let's use the data
let's sit down and explain things to
people so that they
have a full understanding and then let
them make a decision
you know that's always been the strong
point of who we are as a nation
and we seem to be moving very rapidly
toward
uh you know putting our foot on people's
necks and demanding how they must act
and if they don't act the way we want
them to
we cancel them or we do some other thing
this is
totally antithetical to the principles
of the founding of this nation
and people need to get alarmed about it
and people need to start
talking about it and doing something
about it because
as ronald reagan says you know freedoms
is never more than a generation away
from being lost
yeah i know it's so true i think when
you're analyzing whether or not you want
to elect somebody into public office
you need to get the to the root of their
principle of what they believe the
proper role of government is because if
they don't get that right
then they get the answer to these things
all totally wrong
now in vermont they are saying that you
need to be a person of color
or you can't you don't you don't get to
get in that line
how do you react to that well you know
this this whole
identity politics stuff uh is
is poisonous you know if martin luther
king dr martin luther king were here
today
he would be absolutely offended
you know he wanted people to be judged
by the character and not by the color of
their skin
and here we are doing everything we
possibly can
to separate people on the basis of of
race
religion gender whatever things that we
can find
instead of the united states we're
becoming the divided states
and a house divided against itself
cannot stand
it is the most ridiculous policy
and i i hope that the state of vermont
will very seriously
reconsider and we need to start looking
at our population
in terms of who needs what and working
on the basis of
need rather than the basis of
superficial
identifying qualities
well doctor i thank you for your service
in the trump administration and and
probably even more importantly
your service uh saving countless lives
in in your
your time as being a doctor so thank you
for joining us tonight on hannity we do
appreciate it
thank you for what you're doing and i
hope everybody will recognize that
we have to do this together
amen appreciate it thanks doctor